Oh from eight years ago here's the thing
it's kind of crazy I could kind of see
some Republicans voting form is this
indicative of a guy who's always been
consistent and something else let's say
for a second that that premise let's say
had some truth to it right did you
attend but doesn't that mean that you
have someone who was a professional
couch surfer who was never gainfully
employed for his entire life and if he
didn't change any opinions by the time
he's 98 doesn't that just mean that you
haven't learned anything you can't I
want to talk about something today I
want to start a campaign to make Bernie
Sanders based again so between the
context yes hashtag make Bernie based
again a question of the day bernie is
often portrayed as being sort of a
strong candidate because of his
consistency I've heard a lot he's been
very consistently he hasn't flipped flat
he's been about the same thing as whole
life but but is he I mean easy really
consistent tell me on what issues do you
think Bernie Sanders is most consistent
and what do you really like about a most
or dislike if you're a Republican or
Democrat I'm I'm genuinely curious but I
just have to pull up this thread a
little bit that he's been very
consistent we'll go through the flips
and the flops and I'm not table we're
gonna make a hair joke you'll see the
hair that's because it's just crippling
melanoma oh it's okay I can make that
joke because my dad had melanoma
melanoma pass very complicated phrase
that's consistent I think you might be
surprised at some of the positions that
Bernie Sanders has held so let's start
with this Vox interview from five years
ago which is as unnerving as it is
confusing because Ezra Klein has a job
let's see what Bernie Sanders had to say
about nationalism and immigration here
you go
sharply raising the level of immigration
we permit even up to the up to a level
of open borders without sharply closed
we boarded our NATO bosses that's a coke
brothers proposal I mean that's a
right-wing proposal which says if it
answers at least one but if anybody it
would make it a global poor Richard
that's gonna make everybody in America
poor that you're doing away with with
the concept of a nation-state and I
don't think there's any country on the
world
which believes in that had a DeLorean
and you could fast forward to you five
years from then you have a
representative the country I guess that
would count but otherwise I see your
point
it's just everyone who's trying to get
here doesn't believe in borders I think
really it's people that wanted to get
people here so that they will vote for
them don't believe in borders go layers
deep birds of a feather create entirely
new violent felon floating base bumper
stickers much of you from the sea so
let's let's look at this why this is
important the context is Bernie's
opposition again to immigration is
partly based on nationalist ideas huh
what so let's ignore his socialist
solutions for a second he's itself
without socialist right um he is current
he's not not wrong there if you embrace
this idea of open borders
you really are rejecting the idea of a
nation-state let's just say a nation a
country altogether yeah and again we are
looking at a guy who is openly a
socialist so you combine it you look at
he's a socialist and then this rhetoric
is effectively those of a nationalist so
really he's kind of if you look he's a
nationalist socialist which rings a bell
I don't know that's I think the
comparison is usually lazy but if the
mustache fits okay in this piece which
is so funny because we've seen so many
comparisons to Donald Trump right and
Nazis right look into Nazis here's the
thing I hate Nazis
yes can't stick bad guys dislike Nazis
which is know precisely why I support
President Trump let me explain this is
largely due to the fact that my primary
gripe with the Nazis wasn't the
nationalism more so the socialism and
the extermination is a few other things
in yeah and by the way we both know that
Donald Trump wouldn't be in either of
those camps as seen by the deregulation
that you complain about and his support
for Israel which is met by protest from
today's left so this is one thing it's
important because some will try and say
well the nationalist partner is what
automatic is anti-semitic well then that
would mean that Israel's nationalist
policy is anti-semitic no no nationalism
is not discriminatory it is not racist
it is believing in your nation in first
serving the P
of your country who you've taken an oath
to sir
so when you say Donald Trump's a Nazi
because he's nationalist well we know
that you know nationalism doesn't have
to include anti-semitism because you are
accusing Donald Trump of being a
nationalist as well as being too Pro Jew
so let's do that
I think everyone should be free to say
now not white nationalist not a racial
supremacist national just no nationalism
you're a nationalist that's fine do you
believe that your nation is the greatest
country in the face of you believe the
United States is better than say I don't
know Canada you're a nationalist new
Bernie Sanders are both nationalists
you're just not the socialist part again
but my major gripe with the Nazis the
socialism the killing of the Jews they
went the wrong direction his point is
you can't bring you can't flood the
country with unskilled workers because
you will bring down wages for
middle-class Americans because
middle-class Americans are doing so well
now they've decided to migrate from
discussing the economy to black lives
matter and [ __ ] there's the flip here's
the flop more recently senator Sanders
has explicitly embraced the globalist
model when we talk about foreign policy
it is clear that there are some who
believe that the United States when a
gesture is drawing from the global
community I disagree
as the wealthiest and most powerful
nation on earth we have got to help lead
the struggle to defend and expand a
rules-based international order in which
war not might makes right ring ring
hello Ezra Klein it's not like we pulled
the 1980s video of him this was five
years ago
resident yes and yeah I do look at this
the sash it's like they couldn't put it
on his shoulder he's like cuz he has no
shoulder he's like the tootsie roll owl
where it just goes from his head he's
like the hawk neck challenge right like
his head I think we have another clip
just again to drive home the context
here Bernie Sanders was very clear that
his reason for opposing the idea of open
works was immigrations net effect on
American wages if you believe in a
nation state or in a country called the
United States or UK or Denmark or any
other country you have an obligation
that no I won't be great for them I
don't believe in that I think we have to
raise wages in this country I think we
have to do everything that we can to
create the millions of jobs you know
what youth unemployment in the United
States of America today if you're white
the white kid high school graduates 33%
a Hispanic 36% African American 51% you
think we should open the mortise and
bring in a lot of low-wage workers what
do you think maybe we should try to get
jobs for those kids so I think from a
moral responsibility we've got to do
work with the rest of the industrialized
world to to address the problems of
international poverty but you don't do
that by making people in this country
even poor I mean if that video clip just
existed on an island and I knew nothing
else about Bernie at all I kind of
pulled the lever no plus he's a pretty
good magician he's like nothing up
nothing up my sleeves I have a thumb tip
look at that cut the handkerchief it's
got real magic oh my gosh it's like
Bernie kicked his own ass in this this
is consistent this since the 70s are
complaining about immigrant workers
driving down wages in Delmont and
obviously he sees the solution
differently but essentially he is right
when it comes to the problem bringing
huge amounts of unskilled workers into
the economy generally speaking and we
can get some micro economic it drives
down wages of the American workers this
it's
supply and demand now that was the flip
here's the flop Sanders has said now on
day one of his presidency and we
contrast this with I'm so glad we have
these clips side-by-side he would do
away with any immigration detention
centers and make a path to citizenship
for every single last illegal immigrant
in the United States day one executive
order restore the legal service of 1.8
million young people in the daca program
day one we change border policy so that
federal agents will never snatch babies
from the arms of their mothers over 1 we
introduced an there's day one bernie
still day which will in fact be
comprehensive which will result in a
path toward citizenship for all of the
11 million or undocumented illegal what
about day two again that's the flop you
let me know if you think it's remarkably
consistent we'll go to gun control here
this is one that a lot of people miss
but i didn't forget because remember the
previous democratic debates were they
all oger argued over I said over had a
stroke over yeah they all argued over
who had the lower rating from the NRA
under that and everyone had an F and
they all jumped on Bernie because he
only had a d-minus
he ruined the curve D - is pretty good
with your F's Bernie and you're doing
everything on day one what's the
marathon not a sprint Bernie he had a
pretty reasonably pro-gun record in
Vermont he voted against waiting periods
and background checks by the way for gun
purchases and he also voted to protect
gun companies from being sued by the
victims of shootings and he said this he
said well I don't think that um that
mom-and-pop gun shops and/or firearm
manufacturers should be sued because
somebody want to help and committed some
kind of a mass shooting and by the way
something that's important to note
Vermont has some of the most permissive
gun laws in the country up until
recently I think it just changed last
year you might know those better than
I do anyone over 16 could legally
purchase any firearm with no delay and
they could open or concealed carry
without any permit effective immediately
Wow it's like the Wild West you buy that
firearm in Vermont you buy that firearm
in Vermont you walk out the store you
can carry it where you want it as long
as you are a law-abiding citizen and so
Bernie being you know having worked it
suckled at the government teat for all
of 90 years in Vermont this would have
it was a pretty low population by the
way who tend to be very liberal he
easily could have pushed some kind of
gun control measures in Vermont and you
need to start with anything like a
magazine ban you need to start with
anything radical just could have been
hey like most states even the
conservative ones will need some kind of
a concealed carry permit process but he
didn't he never did he was very pro-gun
as he led there legislatively in Vermont
here's the flop
let's compare that to the platform he's
running on right now we need to take on
the NRA expand background checks and the
gun show loophole and ban a sale and
distribution of assault weapons we don't
have them Bernie by the way I do love
that like that's the one clip out of all
the ones we've seen where it looks like
finally a he looks like he's Thomas
Edison on light bulb 342 the one with
power kite I know it's been a Ben
Franklin but you understand because
that's no reason to merge I need no more
justification historico lee inaccurate
after criticism from Hillary Clinton he
then co-sponsored a bill to repeal
protections for gun manufacturers Yeah
right so in other words he was he's
really looking for that F he was for it
before he was against he really wants
the eff though the same idea that he
previously had I'm trying to go back and
forth it's like the inception of
flip-flops he was against the idea of
being a blowgun and then he said bill he
was fourth the point is I'm not
consistent from eight years ago here's
the thing it's kind of crazy I could
kind of see some Republicans voting form
at that point but again my question to
you
is this indicative of a guy who's always
been consistent and something else let's
say for a second that that premise let's
say had some truth to it right did you
attend but doesn't that mean that you
have someone who was a professional
couch server who was never gainfully
employed for his entire life and if he
didn't change any opinions by the time
he's 98 doesn't that just mean that you
haven't learned anything you can't have
it both ways is consistency a good thing
or is the ability to change your mind
and adapt a good thing but it's a trick
question because he does neither of it I
hope you enjoyed this clip if you don't
these are the ABCs of me baby you can
just click Next video and put it in
double speed of course search doesn't
necessarily work subscriptions
notifications don't necessarily work
just bookmark this page chicken we do a
new video every single day except for
Sunday and if you don't want this
content to disappear join my club at
Ladder with credit comm slash Mudd Club
it's only $69 if your student veteran or
active military and if you don't you
know listen I I don't want to say that
your hellbound but it that doesn't look
good for you